2025, AND EVENTUALLY TACKLE
HUMAN EXPLORATION OF MARS.
>> AND A LOT OF NEW EXPERIMENTS
FOR THE MOON.
CNN'S SPACE AND DEFENSE
CORRESPONDENT KRISTIN FISHER IS
LIVE AT THE KENNEDY SPACE
CENTER.
A LOT OF STOPS AND STARTS,
QUESTIONS IF THEY COULD COMPLETE
THIS AND NOW THE SCRUB.
DO WE KNOW THE FULL SCOPE?
ARE RT WE DON'T KNOW THE FULL
SCOPE.
ABOUT 91 NASA ENGINEERS ARE
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT IF THIS IS
A FEW DAY DELAY OR, PERHAPS,
LONGER.
WE HAVE A BACKUP LAUNCH ATTEMPT
ON FRIDAY.
A THIRD ATTEMPT ON MONDAY.
IF THIS IS SOMETHING THEY CAN
FIX ON THE LAUNCHPAD.
IF IT'S NOT SOMETHING THEY CAN
FIX ON THE LAUNCHPAD, THEN
THEY'LL HAVE TO ROLL IT BACK TO
THE VERTICAL ASSEMBLY BUILDING,
WHICH TAKES ABOUT THREE DAYS.
YOU'RE LOOKING AT A MUCH LONGER
DELAY THERE.
WE'RE AWAITING A PRESS
CONFERENCE LIKELY LATER TODAY AT
SOME POINT FROM NASA TO WALK US
THROUGH WHAT EXACTLY WENT WRONG
AND HOW QUICKLY THEY THINK THAT
THEY CAN FIX IT.
BUT LET ME JUST KIND OF WALK YOU
THROUGH WHAT EXACTLY WE KNOW
HAPPENED.
FIRST, THERE WAS A LIGHTNING
STRIKE ISSUE THIS MORNING.
LIGHTNING GETTING TOO CLOSE TO
THE PAD.
THEY WERE ABLE TO MOVE PAST THAT
STORM.
THEN THERE WAS A HYDROGEN LEAK
ISSUE.
THEY WERE ABLE TO FIX THAT.
THEN THERE WAS WHAT THEY THOUGHT
WAS A CRACK IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
MAIN TANK OR A LINE OF FROZEN
FOAM, ESSENTIALLY.
THEY WERE ABLE TO CLEAR THAT AND
CONTINUE WITH LAUNCH.
BUT IT WAS THE FOURTH PROBLEM
THAT WE ENCOUNTERED THIS MORNING
THAT PROVED TO BE THE REASON FOR
THE SCRUB TODAY.
AND TO EXPLAIN EXACTLY WHAT THE
ISSUE IS, I'M GOING TO SHOW YOU
THIS MODEL.
THIS IS OBVIOUSLY NOT OF THE
ARTEMIS SLS ROCKET.
THIS IS OF THE SPACE SHUTTLE,
BUT IT REALLY WORKS HERE BECAUSE
THE SLS ROCKET IS KIND OF LIKE A
FRANKENSTEIN ROCKET IN THE SENSE
THEY COBBLED TOGETHER ALL SORTS
OF DIFFERENT PARTS.
THIS IS THE MAIN CORE STAGE
RIGHT HERE.
JUST IMAGINE THAT THE SPACE
SHUTTLE IS NOT ON IT.
WHAT THEY DID ALL THE WAY AT THE
BOTTOM OF THIS MAIN BURNT ORANGE
CORE STAGE IS WHERE THE ROCKETS
ARE.
THERE'S FOUR ROCKETS.
THEY ARE CALLED RS-25 -- EXCUSE
ME, FOUR ENGINES.
THEY ARE CALLED RS-25 ENGINES.
THE SAME ENGINES, THE CYLINDERS
RIGHT DOWN HERE AT THE BOTTOM OF
THE SPACE SHUTTLE, THEY WERE
TAKEN FROM A SHUTTLE, PUT ON THE
BOTTOM OF THE MAIN CORE STAGE ON
THE SLS ARTEMIS ROCKET.
AND IT WAS ONE OF THOSE ROCKETS
ENGINES THAT'S CAUSING PROBLEMS
TODAY.
SPECIFICALLY THOSE ENGINES NEED
TO BE COOLED TO A VERY PRECISE
TEMPERATURE IN ORDER FOR THE
ROCKET TO LIFT OFF.
AND FOR WHATEVER REASON, NASA
OFFICIALS WERE NOT COMFORTABLE
THAT THAT ONE ROCKET ENGINE HAD
HIT THE PRECISE TEMPERATURE THAT
THEY NEEDED FOR LIFT-OFF.
SO, THAT'S WHY WE'RE HERE TODAY
AND THAT'S WHY THIS FIRST TEST
FLIGHT HAS BEEN SCRUBBED.
JIM AND POPPY, I THINK IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT TO POINT OUT THAT THIS
IS A TEST FLIGHT.
NASA OFFICIALS HAVE BEEN
STRESSING THIS FROM DAY ONE.
WE KNEW THIS COULD BE A VERY
LIKELY OUTCOME TODAY.
THEY'VE NEVER GOTTEN THIS FAR IN
THE COUNTDOWN.
SO, WE KNOW THAT THEY'RE GOING